oh man
oh that feels good oh that feels good oh
that feels good oh man all I did was
calm down after my rage and I just I
focused my way through it home man I did
it guys I did it okay hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
Mario maker I did it oh boy oh oh joy
Issei okay so now I'm gonna give that a
star and I'm gonna leave a comment cuz
I've never left comment and I'm playing
on Ryan's wheeze so it's gonna be a
comment from Ryan has received the maxim
that was cool right I'm gonna try some
of Ross's other levels you know I did
that though I did it I did it all I did
it guys I did it I did the thing I
should feel good about that but it felt
like all the joy got sucked out of my
heart what am i doing I don't even know
what this is oh god oh god what the hell
please no oh god oh no I don't even this
one had a lot of plays on it and looks
simple so I was under the assumption
that it wouldn't be terribly difficult
yeah [ __ ] okay oh oh oh I know I know
what you want
boink oh well alright then but I can do
this I know I know what it wants I know
what it wants I almost did what it
wanted right away my god this nobody
wants I think anyway [ __ ] shitty shitty
oink-oink okay so I bet it wants me to
go high enough to the point where I'll
be able to do what I need to do and I
don't know if I could just not do that
or maybe I need to kill the Bowser's
because I think the other Bowser died
from something or other I'm not entirely
sure what oh I need to go okay so I
can't jump on your head bozer
oh hey bozer so maybe I'm supposed to oh
I can't do that at all okay all right
then that's a no-go for me that was can
you get off of that perch I need that
for stuff and things
oh excuse me [ __ ] I'm a winner I'm a
winner I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm a
winner I'm a winner I'm a winner oh oh
what's with the secret door what what
does what's with the secret door Oh No
Wow whatever I don't have time to worry
about that I am a winner and there's all
the matters with my life whoo maybe
there's another door that just leads you
into the death maybe that's that's what
Ross would do isn't it that's what Ross
would do that Ross would just leave you
into death okay so I completed a level
in a single video oh so happy I think
you're not sure though okay so there is
another companion spring level that I
could do next but do I want to is the
question so okay yeah I'll give it a go
I'm gonna give this just a couple
episodes unless I can just one shot at
like a freaking boss which is probably
not what's gonna happen but even so I
have seen the grumps try this one that's
a bad start but then again that's what I
expected but I know that I'm good at
this and I can do this
do this there we go okay now we got it
give me your shoes thank you oh crap
crap I'm a winner I'm the winner okay so
if I keep this up I've got a lot of
momentum riding on this I can just yes
yes perfect Oh God not perfect that was
not perfect but I wonder if I could spin
jump on those and completely ignore no I
need the spring that's what I need
okay so there's got to be a way that I
can do this well I mean obviously
there's a way that I can do this by
doing it the right way give gift thank
you what was with the delay okay I have
seen the ground service but I know for a
fact that Ross did not put in a frickin
cheat to this level he put in nothing
and just made someone else try for four
hours to beat the stupid game so that's
that's that's the way that Ross worked
on this one so if I can beat this I
would be unwise why'd that not no no no
no no no no no just no no no no no no no
no no no no come on what is with this
just go up the thing oh damn it Oh frak
frak my necks ooh that is that is a
pleasant tingle in my throat thank you
for being late to the party you ass bag
that is the dickery that is dickory up
there I should have been up that pipe
ten million ways to Sunday but it
decided to be a anyway so that happened
I guess so that's good for me I'm so
happy about that alright that happened -
that was another way that I could have
died you know I'm trying to explore out
the options here there's a lot of
variety in this I was just hitting the
left stick I wasn't even doing anything
on that one I was not pressing the stick
to the right at all well apparently you
just can't go right away you gotta wait
patiently for half a freaking second
because that's how this level is
designed because if you go right off the
bat you're just gonna die like an idiot
it's little things it's the little
things it's thank you it's the little
things that really make me happy happy
and happy and happy and happy happy
happy happy happy happy happy part we
are this
patience patience patience oh good
Wow
that you know I wouldn't have thought
that could like hurt like physically
hurt like you know frustration to the
point of physical pain that oh oh that
hurt that hurt whoa that was not a fun
experience oh oh it's just like my heart
just jolted out of my chest
it's not cool whoa okay
okay not today [ __ ] there we go just a
half second waiting there half second at
the beginning a half second they're all
kosher and cool whoa oh I don't know how
that happened but this is easy thank you
thank you for making my life a little
bit less terrible all right I'm trying
to remember exactly what I was supposed
to do from the other one
Wow it did not seem like I was gonna
make that but why was it just enough
over that I the spin jump didn't let me
it's the little things it's the little
things that gets to me it's the little
things that make my chest hurt little
things just itty-bitty things all right
little itty-bitty things that get on
your nerves and make you think very dark
thoughts about Ross but it's not Ross's
fault why would it be Ross's fault
he only made the damn thing thank you
thank you for being a whole tastic okay
so what did you do that whoa cease what
did what then god damn it
just don't
Oh ah that freaking hurts my heart oh oh
oh I don't know you know I've wanted to
like ask people about this for a long
time and I don't know if I've ever
mentioned this on a video you know you
know like have as any of you ever
experienced like levels of frustration
that just makes you hurt down in your
groin like just ball pain like just it
makes you feel like you gotta pass a
kidney stone out here you where you're
normally passing oh god not this
thank you does it make you feel like you
got to pass a kidney stone you know it's
just it's pain like weird weird
unbelievably undescribable pain when
it's you're like trying to thread a
needle and it's not going you know what
I'm you know what I'm talking about like
that weird feeling in your you know oh
god no oh god oh god no not tonight not
tonight okay
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video I need to go walk I need to go pet
my dog I need to go beloved I need to
feel happiness